hey guys how's it going I am so excited
cuz I've got a special guest who she's
gotta sneak around to this little area
that I shoot in it looks a lot bigger on
camera okay I did not expect for it to
be this tight what's up guys oh my gosh
see I never shoot with an external
monitor do you look so now I'm like oh
did you look at it don't look at it
don't you can't no keg I know I'm
looking at well this is Sarah DG rhymes
with PG and today we are gonna be I was
gonna say unboxing but it's got an
envelope on enveloping yeah it's
something like that what do I biggest
complaint from the new Apple watch it
has a red dot I completely agree with
you I did when I saw that I was like
okay this is a good differentiator to
show up to your friends and you got the
LTE version but it's been interesting
because a lot of people have said oh you
have the new one which basically this is
what it looks like when I tweeted about
not liking the red color you guys sent
me this as a suggestion it's called
cheilitis watchdogs that's exactly I
don't really like the black but guess
what I have you can have wait first we
discussed the fact that now you have
converted one side so I've gotten that
38 from from the gang I told you guys
which Apple watch I ended up with and it
is at the 38 white it I was actually
touched since I was likes me by the way
what size watch do you have because I
was curious yeah I was like oh my gosh I
did not realize that the 42 was too big
I mean it took up my entire wrist and
like it would did not fit at all and I
didn't even know it so I've been doing
that for like two years
sure you go so we do it here let's show
that first but it would be cool to just
have solid white it really would
actually I'm pretty sure I ordered solid
white so we'll see
I don't even remember I ordered the
Salonika look at this unboxing it they
have a special gifts cool so apparently
what I did originally order was for this
for this so they included free ones to
cover up the red which is what I
wanted
wait is that there I guess the job
I don't know there you go
look at that okay that looks clean once
for the power button - so if you want to
have to match your watchbands you could
do that they come in so many different
colors so I've got a oh there's three
sets in each we've got a fog grey a
black just in case
so XL y XL edition our size to cover the
red digital crown so the XL ones are the
new ones to cover the the new box right
so but this is cool too because mmm if
you wanted to add a little black to
yours you could right here's a white
after you
this is I'm so excited that you wanted
to the challengers up to these look like
a little bigger video cover like if you
have a buster like a band-aid so here's
some instructions all right oh shoot I
can't see it as I'm trying to look at
this screen Oh
use a pair of scissors to carefully go
scissors we're already behind let's just
use this in a well-lit area okay this is
pretty literally I think it lit enough
this is more of a time commitment
gently peel away the paper you need some
epic music for this yes
okay future this scene
epic music I didn't do a very good job
so there we go I mean I see the vision I
see it yeah us there so this is the
excel so maybe I mean excel because like
I was scared to put it on some black
around yeah I guess the excel makes
sense then hmm it's okay this is why
they give you multiple one yes how much
are these yeah that's a good question it
was not very much that looks really good
I think I got it
it's like perfect if I'm so nervous I'm
like I'm like I'm shaking yeah I'm
shaking just gonna stare about your
shoulders and make this more intense I
mean this is like the same thing as
putting a screen protector on the top of
your phone sharp angle sharp angle that
sharp that's sharp Wow it looks it looks
go really good no I like that I'm into
it pretty fresh
[Music]
look at that I love that that looks good
it's the alcohol black leather it looks
good you all right nice man we're gonna
be so stylish $9.99 I guess you get
three it's a little piece of vinyl no
this trim that's true but it is very
accurately cut they have lots of
different colors and yes they do give
you so what are the color awesome Wow
I mean they've got red black white
midnight blue yellow
look at that support I like you know I
mean I kind of do like the different
accent color sprays both of it you can
know I like that wow that looks so good
I think we need a Apple watch watch dot
lifestyle lookbook I think you should
let have filmy like walking around in LA
and just like sporting it I think okay
yeah I think we'll do that right now
[Music]
can you feel
[Laughter]
well guys thanks so much for watching
and thank you Sarah for cramming back
here in this time you thank you I my
watch stopped yeah do you want to like
another color or something you later I
think this is like all I need way okay I
that's the only thing that bothered me
the blunt dot and I think it looks good
it does look good I'm actually pretty
surprised good it does look really good
this is great
well thanks again for hanging out make
sure you guys go check out Sarah's
channel I'll put links in the
description and at which side is the ion
left my like my love you
I think I've studied this so hard every
time if I go like this I go but I think
aside okay it's over here
[Music]